poco antes de cumplirse el mediodía en
estocolmo la Real Academia sueca de
ciencias anunció que serían tres los
ganadores del premio Nobel de física de
este año Alan aspecto de Francia John
closer de Estados Unidos y anton
sailinger de Austria recibieron el
premio por experimentos con fotones
entrelazados que establecieron la
violación de las desigualdades de Bell y
fueron Pioneros en la ciencia de la
información cuántica
quien trabaja en la universidad de Viena
habló tras el anuncio admitió estar
sorprendido e insistió en que el premio
fue un esfuerzo de colaboración pleno
son eso solo fue posible porque tuve la
oportunidad desde muy temprano de hacer
las cosas que me interesaban en física
sin pensar si podría tener un propósito
en alguna parte
por el contrario Durante los días de los
experimentos la prensa me preguntaba
para qué servía y yo decía puedo decirle
con orgullo que es inútil Solo estoy
haciendo esto por curiosidad porque
estaba completamente fascinado por la
física cuántica desde la primera vez que
escuché de ella
se espera que el trabajo del Trío
conduzca importantes avances en la
computación cuántica y la tecnología de
detección el entrelazamiento cuántico
permite conectar dos partículas sin
enviar ninguna señal entre ellas durante
la tarde del 4 de octubre la asamblea
nacional de Francia ovacionó aspec el
décimo cuarto ganador francés del premio
otro impulso al sector de la ciencia y
la tecnología del país
[Aplausos]